my advice to everyone out there who's
frustrated sad angry pissed off feel
those emotions go to a kickboxing class
have a margarita do whatever you need to
do this weekend and then wake up on
monday morning we got to keep fighting
it's been a doozy of a week for the
biden white house after joe baum during
his one year news conference so the
white house has a new plan
the president will take a back seat on
trying to pass his agenda that the
country hates and instead joe's going to
go on tour to try to convince americans
to like him again
it's a reflection of how he wants to
spend his time and his recognition that
he wants to spend more time out in the
country and less time behind closed
doors negotiating it's a reflection of
how
our own
of of his view which we share of how we
can best use his time and there's
nothing more valuable than the
president's time but joe may need to
lend some of his delusional confidence
to his vp after kamala harris summed up
their first year in this
less than inspiring way
the first
year of the biden-harris administration
it is time
that is defined a time that is defined
by uncertainty
the people in this zoom have been
steadfast
and you have never stopped believing in
what is possible and in our work to
achieve that future together and don't
you dare question biden about his shaky
policies or he'll give you a stern
talking too
biden's first year has been such a bust
that even time magazine put out this
very special cover to commemorate his
time in the oval office but all it does
is remind people how bleak
the last year's been
so greg you know you just got to have a
drink you got to go to kickboxing class
isn't that obvious
she
is my kind of lady
when you're faced with serial pro
serious problems
resort to violence and booze
beat someone up perhaps a stranger
get loaded
marry me you red devil she's she is the
best thing
about this administration i mean just
compared to how she was speaking to the
vice president right it's like you're
there's just no there's no competition
but i think this sally field strategy
for j for uh president uh biden not
gonna work all right you know it's not
this it's not
we've we've come to the conclusion that
less is more with joe wildly popular
when he was chained to the rusted
peloton bike or soloflex gotta get my
analogy straight in the basement and
then when he came out of the basement
the numbers dropped so you don't
actually want to push him out there
here's a better path for joe
if it's not too late stand up to the
woke
steer your party away from the
progressive abyss
and for once and for all burn
your race card because every time you
play the race card you may forget about
it but we all remember it right i mean
he doesn't remember the things he says
about this person and that person he but
but in this case we do remember the idea
of him you know getting out of dc to
make everybody feel good i mean is this
gonna be like you know a back rub bus
tour or is it gonna be like uh is it
gonna be like a box car biden with magic
fingers on a train it's just all it's
gonna do is it's gonna remind you that
the guy that was before him wasn't so
bad biden has been a real boon for trump
because we all have got a four year bre
we're getting a break to look back and
go wow the orange godzilla he actually
did a lot of good stuff you know he did
all right he got he was able to quell
like north korea we had those uh uh
those uh middle east peace accords we
had a vaccine we had an explosive
economy before coven he was the first
excuse me i spit
he's the first guy to really go off on
china and then everybody had to catch up
with them so you know and so when you
have this break
it's really benefit benefited trump but
it's also benefited the republican party
right they they're like they're they're
suddenly the popular kid at the party
and they haven't done anything yet so my
advice to them is don't get cocky and
instead of doing politics think about
the people the issues are there you got
you got crime you got inflation you got
food prices you got schools you got
freedom i mean the you know stop playing
politics republicans help the people
then they win that's my advice can we
can we get friday greg the whole week or
do we just have to get them on friday i
you know i just want to go to a bar okay
everybody is out my my staff is already
across the street drinking and i'm
sitting here in my studio all by myself
staring at harold ford which by the way
makes me a very lucky man oh i have
reached out to the white house for
comment on greg's marriage proposal for
the press secretary all right i will let
you know as soon as she gets back yes
it would be
so jillian um
does greg's uh
strategy sound plausible or do you think
joe getting out into the country like
every every president says they're going
to do i got to get out of the white
house do you think that has a better
chance of resuscitating him i mean the
president keeps saying over and over he
said at this press conference two days
ago that his biggest
big kahuna problem right now is the
republican party his opposition to his
party he says republicans are blocking
his built back better legislation
they're blocking his voting rights
legislation he says conservatives at the
supreme court are blocking his mask
mandate but the reality for the
president is that his party is in charge
of the white house the senate the house
he is never going to have a smoother
path forward for implementing his agenda
than he has right now
today
just checking my email oh we've heard
back from jen saki she says a lot of
hope but no chance
striking out as always mr gutfeld i'm
sorry thank god i'm married yeah i mean
it's not that it matters
that's right
all right um harold ford jr you know
what this sounds like when the president
says i'm going to get out in the country
and get out of the white house sounds
like he's just gonna go to more
fundraisers isn't that what this is all
about raise some more money and try to
stem the losses in the midterms
well i think that stemming the losses is
certainly the probably the focus and
maybe the motivation for it but i think
successful presidents
never try to get in front of the people
or behind the people they try to meet
people and walk alongside them
we've had presidents in the past that
have gone through turbulence obviously
reagan did
he at one point was in the mid 30s in
his administration in 1982 he came back
and won clinton was in the high 30s he
came back and won but
obama was at 42 when obamacare passed he
came back and won trump was at 39 and he
didn't come back and win and carter
found himself in the 40s and he didn't
come back and win i think you have to
look back if i were president biden you
look back at those teams and you figure
out what did they do and this is where
this is where greg was right
you have to focus on where people are
crime is the issue that has to be
focused on in so many communities across
the country i was pleased to see brad
d.a bragg here in new york today
well let me get back to that but i think
crime on the mind first of all the
economy is not doing as bad as as some
would suggest we've got to figure out
how we get get get through these supply
chain clocks but crime is an issue you
can that you can lose on clinton lost in
94 the crime bill and crime itself hurt
him in many ways so i think crime and to
your point drilling the economy uh
meaning inflation in the supply chain
and the border and i thought i was glad
to hear the president the other day in
his and his remarks in his press
conference said he's going to be
president now and not try to be a
committee chairman in the senate or even
a majority leader leave that to the
legislative branch and finally mr
president
it's it's best to be like a great
cornerback or like ted lasso says you
forget that last play forget what
happened over the last few months and
move forward find ways to solve problems
don't just do the same thing i'm pleased
to see him get out into the country he
should have been in ohio today with the
intel chief as they announced that 20
billion dollar investment to build
semiconductor chips in america we ought
to identify other cities that can be
innovation hubs as well that's what i
would do if i were in that white house
and i think the president's trying his
hardest to do that one day harold one
day
with me as your speechwriter we're going
places
oh no
that would be the first thing i didn't
do
all right dagon is there gonna be a
biden come back or is the writing on the
wall
no there's gonna be no biden come back
because he's been fully indoctrinated by
the far left and he is not changing
course going out and seeing people is
just trying to convince the rubes and
the deplorables that everything is
actually great he he is not changing
course because he he can't see
the failures
that have developed from his policies he
goes out and thinks everything is okay
and uh and as evidence of that by the
way anywhere biden goes in this country
except maybe new york city and even here
he's going to get booed and that kind of
makes me feel good on the inside i don't
know why but i i like when people you
know
suffer
in public
just a little bit you should hang out
with me
[Laughter]
but just one quick thing the most
stunning thing for me from that press
conference was joe biden talking about
getting more advice from outside experts
from academia to editorial writers and
think tanks
these are fanatical jack jaws that he's
going to for advice and lo and behold
what are we already starting to hear
la times editorial cnn headline price
controls the government needs to
implement price controls because we
don't have enough shortages right now we
really want to kill businesses and have
not just your grocery store shelves
empty but home depot lowe's you name it
you're not going to be able to find
anything so i think joe biden is not
changing except maybe for the worse yeah
i'd fire the experts if i were joe biden
all right we got to go uh we gotta we
got to hurry up to kick boxing and and
drinks so let's get moving hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else